All I've been craving is buffalo wings
with homemade ranch.
And yes, I've
had this meal more than I should have in the past week,
but here we are
making it again.
I know it's controversial,
but you don't have to wash your chicken.
It's a preference thing,
so do whatever you want.
Patted my wings dry and then added some cornstarch
and whatever seasoning your heart desires.
I do smoked paprika,
garlic powder,
Cajun seasoning,
and then I let those hang out on my wire rack
for at least 30 minutes.
Meantime, I make my ranch with some Mayo,
sour cream, buttermilk.
You can also use regular milk,
some dill. Can't forget the parsley and chives.
Squeeze of lemon,
and then I season it with some salt and pepper.
Usually I bake my wings,
but today my husband wanted them fried,
so I did that.
I fried them off in batches and did a double fry
just to get them really nice and crispy.
Once those were done,
I melted some butter in my pot,
added my favorite hot sauce, some honey,
and let that simmer for a little bit just to thicken up.
When it was time to coat the wings,
I put them in a big metal bowl,
poured my sauce over,
but also reserved some on the side
just to drizzle on top.
Gave that really good toss.
Put all of them on my big serving plate
and I like to top them with either cilantro
Parsley or spring onion?
Today we did spring onion.
Can't forget about the ranch I made.
And the ratio of wing to ranch is very important.
But these were so good
that I'll probably be making them again tomorrow.